[Music]
you've survived another season of
housewives did you have the age to come
back full time to come back now I do and
you know the more I'm on I feel I'm like
I'm ready I think I can handle I think I
can handle the drama again I needed a
break for a little while you know to
divorce cancer and those things were
difficult man to get through that and I
didn't want to play the cancer stuff on
camera but I want to support my
foundation I work with so I think it's
really a great platform doing housewives
to get the word out there to support
below-the-belt cancers and the
foundation for women in this cancer so
there you go now did you have to go to
the reunion or did you not you got to
skip out on it I got to Skipton
but I would have liked to have gone I'm
kind of disappointed I didn't get a
chance to because I was involved with a
lot of the filming and I saw some of the
rights and some of the wrongs that were
going on and I'm gonna write some of
those wrongs I'm all about justice so
did you or did you not say that my
sister is close to death
oh god what did i do it's doing great
Kim Richards is doing great she's happy
she's a grandmother this is the best
I've seen her you know I've known her
for several years now I've seen her ups
and downs and I'm not saying she's
blowing she's happy grandmothers you
couldn't be happier Petey caught up with
Camille Grammer at the family equality
councils impact awards over the weekend
I saw a man on your arm earlier as
tonight date night man that you had just
kind of started dating back when we
talked in December right it's going well
I say you look very happy glowy
you